Wow so he so girl looks like he's having
a pretty good time at the moment wonder
what he's doing oh oh I mean look I
guess that's one way to smash that
subscribe button so uh enjoy I guess
hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything and
maeín manga and today it's time to talk
about the creepy magician dude slash nan
genius of hunter hunter
Hisoka and the potential of his future
specifically regarding events to do with
the Dark Continent and I'd like to get
into this because he Sokka is one of the
more endlessly speculated on characters
in the series and currently during all
the succession war business he is
shrouded in a great layer of mystery
either saving him for use in the climax
of the current talk or keeping him in
reserved to take part in the eventual
events of the Dark Continent and a lot
of people will probably stayed at this
point that well Hisoka doesn't have a
lot of reason to actually travel to this
location given his specific goals in
life which as we all know is to gratify
himself by the sourcing and combatting
of strong opponents in many ways it's a
very similar motivation to that of Isaac
Nasra who spent most of his life
constantly in search of a worthy
adversary and I only bring that up
because there is a direct comparison to
be meteor as natura himself did visit
the Dark Continent on two occasions
however after the trip that occurred
when he was still in his comparative
youth Network came to the realization
that there was no strong opponent to be
found on this hellscape and that the
only victory to be had was that of
survival and I can imagine that Hisoka
would find himself in a very similar
situation I mean there were all sorts of
rewards to be gained on the Dark
Continent that could revolutionize
humanity will even provide exceptional
personal benefit he saw himself but none
of that is really in keeping with the
core Drive of this mad magician so
immediately what we need to do to play
see soccer on the Dark Continent is
sourced a strong opponent because of
such a thing were to exist then all
other logic regarding that landmass is
out the window it doesn't matter if he'd
be stepping into Hell itself
Hisoka would most certainly follow in
order to secure an orgasmic fight and
interestingly for him there are going to
be a plethora of powerful figures making
their way to the Dark Continent but more
on them in a second because we do have
some immediate business to take care of
which is the viability of Hisoka
actually surviving the succession war
given that his current targets are the
entirety of the phantom troupe well what
remains of them as well as Ilima zoldak
and we do have to call this into
question because this is set up to be
potentially the end of you soccer in the
series because at the moment
his stated driving force is to kill the
rest of the spiders and of course
crawler himself has been the object of
he soaked his brutal lust much more so
than even our protagonist gone actually
and in this way an argument can be made
that Hisoka and krolow are involved in a
very twisted Romeo and Juliet style
scenario whereby they are destined to
fight and potentially kill each other
aboard the black whale one and yes I
know that's not at all how Romeo and
Juliet went this is just one of those
scenarios where I didn't fully think
that sentence out but I'm not changing
it but that battlefield could of course
be the Dark Continent itself because one
way that this does work out quite well
would be if he so can manage to kill you
know the majority of the troop during
the succession war thus prompting
krohler
to follow him on to the arena of the
Dark Continent that is a very long-term
game plan though and it's entirely
likely that the succession wall will see
the end of the phantom troop and the
reason why I say that goes all the way
back to the infamous interview with
Takashi and volumes 0 where he stated
that in the end krupka and the phantom
troupe will all die now various people
have had different interpretations of
this some view it as a jerk for example
but without any inclination of Takashi's
turn due to it being a written answer I
am inclined to believe that Takashi
really meant what he was saying at least
at that time because you know he has
known to change his mind from time to
time when push comes to shove and one of
those moments would be to cancel death
of machi which we might get back to
briefly but just to finish this thought
the troop are effectively confirmed to
all end up dead by the end of the series
and that does leave the potential that
Hisako would be the sole survivor of
that squabble due to a combination of
taking advantage of the chaos aboard
black whale which is already being
stirred by Marina and the other mafia
powers as well as his newly upgraded
post-mortem nan which would leave him in
a position without a goal and needing a
new crush to move on to and really the
only situation in which I don't see
Hisoka surviving the succession war is
firstly the aforementioned event where
crawler was finally able to kill him
well another figure I briefly brought up
being machi so of everyone in the
Phantom troupe machi has by far the
closest I guess we'll call it a
relationship with ahsoka as he is seen
blatantly propositioning her at various
points in the series and for purposes
that aren't fights to the death
which is weird who knew he Sokka had
regular desires from time to time but
machi was the subject of an interesting
piece of decision making from takashi as
Hisoka was originally supposed to kill
her when he came back to life thanks to
post-mortem nan Bungie gum but Tadashi
at the last minute decided that machi
had a greater purpose in the story one
that he himself wasn't aware of at
but he had a hunch and I would submit
that that hunch is almost certainly
linked Hisoka directly because she is
pretty hell-bent on killing him right
now
so other than crawler I can see a
situation in which it is machi that
finally puts an end to our magician
however should this not occur during the
events of the succession war or even at
all Hisoka has one of two options either
he stays with the cocoon Empire who are
being dumped on the new continent or he
moves on with the rest of the team to
the actual Dark Continent
and given that there aren't likely to be
any strong targets left within the
cocking Empire I think that leaves
Hisoka with a fairly simple choice being
to follow the strong and one of the
primary motivations I can see for Hisoka
landing on the dark continent has
entirely to do with a certain Jing
freaks because during the hunter
chairman election arc he's all khmer dit
very clear that he was looking for Jing
and that he was a prime target in his
mind for a good old fashioned round of
fisticuffs but that's not it because
during that time he Sokka also names
several other zodiac members being
Kansai Ginter and peon who all ranked
very highly on his personal scale of
desire with the potential for other
members to be added as well like I'd
find it very difficult to believe that
he Sokka was not at all interested in
multiplied for example as he is the
eldest member of the group and one of
the rare triple star hunters that this
series has to offer another one of which
would be the current chairman Qi Liu
Yorkshire but I can't imagine he so
cannot being particularly interested in
her in any case the entire point of this
was to list the possibility of many
other targets and we don't even stop
there because there's also another very
exciting from the perspective of ahsoka
figure who will be attending the Dark
Continent party and that is beyond
network now we don't actually have any
insight into he soaked his thoughts
regarding beyond however we are very
well aware of how he felt in regards to
beyond father Isak as during the hunter
exam Hisoka quite boldly challenged
natural when he was asked who he would
and would not prefer to fight in the
final round of course net or casually
dismissed this and sent him away but it
goes to show that he Sokka can be quite
smitten by the network clan and just
imagine his sheer excitement when he
learns of the possibility of another
netter oh but one even stronger than
that of Isaac Metro as implied with his
name beyond and to be perfectly honest
with you I can see he Sokka and Beyond
on the Dark Continent becoming yet
another twisted love story it also
brings up another intriguing thought
because at the moment it would seem that
beyond is being built up as the ultimate
antagonist of this entire expedition and
if he Sokka words take a keen interest
in this man then that
put him on the other end of that
spectrum which dare I say it would be a
protagonist and there is a very good
argument to be made that Hisoka is
indeed already a protagonist of the
series alongside gonk Rebecca kilowatt
and Leo do because we do tend to follow
his perspective quite a lot during most
oxidize involved in Bob hunter exam
where he was an obvious antagonist but
other than that he's always been a much
more intriguing figure operating in an
independent party of his own but this is
important because in regards to the Dark
Continent arc the one thing we are
desperately missing at the moment is a
protagonist and some people's first
thoughts in regards to this going to be
well what about Cara Baca and for
reasons I've already gone into great
detail explaining in another video I do
think the karapa cos story is set to
when during the succession war link in
the description below if you're keen on
checking out those thoughts in more
detail but basically all of his story
threads have been planted into this
cartoon Empire business and he has a
multitude of death flags at this point
due to the extended use of emperor time
meaning that he is rapidly losing his
natural lifespan with every day he
spends aboard the black whale one and I
mean I explained it much better in the
video but this is more than likely going
to leave us with an open slot for a
protagonist when we actually get to the
Dark Continent and with that in mind
there really aren't that many options
one choice could be lay Oreo I guess but
he is woefully unprepared to be homing
the biggest and most dangerous task ever
undertaken in this series and Tadashi
does seem to enjoy having him relegated
to the background though there is kind
of that the other choice I could
potentially think of is to use Jing as
our main protagonist during the Dark
Continent because apart from beyond he
does seem to be the one with the most
natural drive to be there in general bus
he's also a freaks so there's a nice
natural connection to go on there but
failing that I really don't see why we
couldn't have a scenario where he Sokka
that the first time in the series apart
from his battle with Carollo in Heaven's
arena could be our primary eyes for the
ark because if nothing else that Hisoka
versus crawler fight to prove that he
Sokka is a captivating figure who we
could follow almost exclusively with you
know maybe a side dish of Jing but in
the end there it is upon further
inspection Hisoka despite having no
interest in the Dark Continent itself
does have a lot of compelling reasons to
be present during that eventual arc and
a pretty damn fine chance of actually
surviving the events of the succession
war barring an untimely death from
crawler but that didn't work so well
last time
even when crawler had maximum advantage
but also Takashi's may be important use
of machi and that's a big maybe time in
any case he so continues to be one of
the most
compelling characters in the entirety of
Hunter hunter and he has a lot of
potential to sow chaos in what promises
to be one of if not the most insane arc
that the series has ever produced if we
ever get there that is but of course
that is a whole different discussion and
that pretty much does it for my thoughts
and he soaked his potential in the Dark
Continent arc if you enjoyed this video
and the content this channel produce in
general then please do consider donating
to the New World review patreon because
the support of all of your amazing
people is what continues to make this
channel possible and if patreon isn't
quite your style then please do leave
this video will like share or subscribe
because it also help support this
channel an incredible amount and if
you'd like to join the fun at any time
and please to head over to my discord
server where a wide array of shenanigan
takes place on a daily basis and finally
please do comment with your thoughts on
Hisoka and the Dark Continent this has
been the new alter view and I'll see you
next time put a review of Gintama
alright that's um it's not really a
question but ok I mean not ok because
I'm very unlikely to do it actually
Gintama is just such a beast of a series
that I have tried to get into on many
occasions and I do quite like it but
I've never really gotten truly hooked by
it the characters are cool and funny
enough but I always end up losing
interest early on because comedies can
be tricky like that it also might not
help that I always try to start from the
beginning of Gintama and the beginning
is well the first ton of chapters in
episodes are very much a product of its
time and it's very questionable in
regards to how well the comedy of those
initial stages has aged I'm sure I'll
get into it properly one day I usually
do with these things I mean if I
eventually got into Jojo than I'm Shogun
Tama is only a matter of time still I
don't know how much I'll be covering it
on this channel if at all sorry